you know people have been keeping track
of all of the winds in JK party I'm in
second place you know that right well
yeah I would be your first place if I
just if I played on that thing to Dan
guys guess what watch me son hit us up
and they were like hey guys we want you
guys check out our brand new 2016 Nissan
Altima 3.5 SL
oh my goodness we got the key hey what's
up guys um today TIFF and I are gonna be
playing all Tomatoes it's a card game
that Nissan has developed and has given
us a copy of the game look at that that
is so awesome basically it's a road game
it's like the perfect game to play if
you're just trying to ID and have fun
with some friends I think it's sort of
kind of like a truth or dare but they're
all just theirs so the way we're playing
is the driver which could be either
human right there's like you know we'll
sit around I get to play okay fine you
can have the first round he'll be the
driver so the driver picks one red card
right so then the passengers everyone
else in the car which would only just be
me today we get to pick two of these
ultimatum cars and what these cards have
it's kind of like the truth or dare kind
of thing I was talking about right now
but it's mainly just dares so they kind
of just dare you to do things and since
we choose two cards we get to decide
which one out of the two we want to do
so I'm really excited for this game
because I've never played a car card
card card game yeah like a card game and
yeah it's pretty cool and then these
this a card holder sits perfectly in the
cup holder so we are gonna get this game
started right right now in the comments
who do you think is gonna win
I'm ready done all right read drive down
to the nearest car wash here we are the
nearest car wash which is me Alhambra
car wash so we're here okay so Casey's
parking now it's my turn to pull the two
ultimatum cards so here are my
ultimatums
I have feeler dashboard drum solo or
empty your pocket purse or what handbag
handbag in the back seat for all to see
okay hmm
Oh anything you could draw this stuff oh
yeah I'm like totally matte what is this
what is this thing you always do no no
show me this you always do that
okay so you want to see a dashboard drop
so though dashboard yeah oh yeah it's
for you to do I don't have a dashboard
okay do some fills and then never done
this
alright ok since I'm the driver I get
too cold
we read card let's see drive to the top
of your parking garage that's another
close look cool we got we lucked out
high five bust a move
oh I was I had a dream last night and I
realized that Jeffrey isn't the best
name for this car really why because we
could have called this car his this
car's name last name could have been
tima and we could call him al al team
uh-oh
here so we have reached the very top Wow
beautiful
okay so you get to draw your ultimatum
cards all right
ultimatum deck ready ready park the car
and post a selfie of your entire group
of finger mustaches or
compare who in the car has the
best-looking driver's license photo
ahh
hmm pretty juicy for both yeah let me
see you this degree nice thing which one
should we pick you wanna baby okay so
which would be better driver's license
Oh selfie hey let's go with computer
drivers like oh I got a good look into
it quite a flattering picture of me okay
so here we go
driver's license pose gotta hide the
vitals I love that my signature looks
like chicken scratch
who is the best sucker I'm mystified I
don't know I think I'd go with yours cuz
me I took this driver's license when I
was 18 and I had just given birth to
Isaac so I was little more around around
the cheese your darker to a hunter that
way to our girl do you do that has
darker hair so and then I prettier skin
is darker i braided my hair more towards
the middle too so it's kinda different
yeah and then yours how old are you when
you took here this was like this was
like two years ago my foot really new
yeah like you losing my driver's license
I have lose thinking and my license is
one of those things that I think one
time I had to like retake the photo so
this is really new it's back when I have
my faux hawk still this driver's license
its new its new were send this photo
because I remember I went to go get a
new license after I turned 21 because I
wanted you know I wanted it to
not have the underage stuff and so I got
any license and I took a new photo and
I'm like cool I'm gonna update my
driver's license to this 21 year olds
face and not the 18 year olds face
anymore but when I got the license in
the mail they still sent me with the old
photo I think it's really cool that the
two of us we happen to be smiley types
for the driver's license there's a lot
of people that don't smile for their
driver's license which is which is fine
but I think it makes it a lot more
pleasant
it's over and they have a smiley face to
look either like all this guy's a nice
guy yeah but there's a common
misconception of people thinking that
they can't smile during their their
photos so yeah yeah not anymore so smile
away make the officer happy yeah I make
sure you look good for your driver's
license yeah but thanks for watching us
play the Nissan ultimatum card game it's
been really fun it's a pretty fun game
alright guys thanks for watching bye